Prof: Okay,
let's start in.
Got a fairly large agenda today.
And I wanted to remind you that
next week, we're moving on to
air quality.
So check your syllabus and read
the material for section next
week.
And today I want to talk about
two principles in law,
one being preemption and the
other being defamation,
and to give you a couple of
case histories.
And I'm going to start out
talking about Bates v.
Dow.
And then I want to talk about
two cases, one,
product disparagement,
and the other one is known as
the Alar case.
And another is a case that was
brought by the Texas Cattlemen's
Association against Oprah
Winfrey.
And I'll show you a couple of
video clips of that.
First of all,
preemption has its origin in
the Constitution,
within the supremacy clause
that states,
"This Constitution and the
laws of the U.S.
shall be the supreme law of the
land, and the judges in every
state shall be bound
thereby."
So that within air quality law,
within pesticide management
law,
within pharmaceutical law,
tobacco law,
occupational law,
states are prohibited from
adopting certain standards that
are different than the federal
government.
And the purpose behind this is
not to create a patchwork quilt
that is really comprised of
non-uniform standards so that
when corporations wish to trade
goods or provide services across
state boundaries,
they basically have the
expectations.
It's often applied to
situations that are risky or
products that are risky.
And the failure to warn is
often a key question.
And we'll raise that in the
case today.
With respect to pesticides,
Congress traditionally deferred
to states to regulate threats to
health and safety.
But since 1970,
it's exercised its power to
preempt state or local
regulation in a number of areas,
particularly with respect to
warning labels on pesticides.
So there are a variety of
theories of damage recovery.
So if you imagine that say
someone comes to your home and
promises to give you a green
lawn by applying fertilizers and
insecticides,
and all of a sudden you notice
an acrid taste in your well
water,
and also your children start to
feel awkward or strange.
And you find out that the
chemicals that were applied were
neurotoxic substances.
And what are your rights?
Basically, you could argue
that-- we have percussion
section out there on the street,
throwing I think rocks or
bricks into one of these big
metal barrels.
So I apologize for that.
So you can imagine yourself in
a situation where you conclude
that federal law didn't protect
you against that.
You feel like you've been
damaged.
It's going to cost you money to
either drill a new well or to
put infiltration equipment.
And what about the health
effects on your family?
So there are a variety of
theories of damage recovery.
And one is that the failure to
warn provides a justification
for seeking recovery of damages.
So remember what I argued about
the difficulty that most people
have in understanding warning
labels,
the difficulty of taking
complicated scientific
information and reducing it in a
way that would make it
intelligible and make you
capable of knowing how you
should behave in order to
prevent risk.
For example,
should you be responsible to
know that you have sandy soils
and that your well is a shallow
well,
and it's an old well,
and the casing is cracked?
I mean, are you really
responsible to know that?
Should that information be on a
warning label?
Negligence is another theory
for recovery.
So was the product made in a
negligent way or was it used in
a negligent way?
How about design defects?
Listening to Good Morning
America today,
I was intrigued by litigation
that is growing,
class action suits against
Toyota because of their
accelerator pad catching,
or brake defects.
So some defect in production or
design that leads to a higher
level, higher concentration of
risk or hazard and subsequent
damage.
How about failure to disclose
incident reports?
So that Dow Chemical Company
was fined nearly $800,000
because it had been reported to
Dow by a variety of families
that they felt that they had
medical problems that were
associated with using their
products.
And they were required under
federal pesticide law to report
those incidents back to the
Environmental Protection Agency,
and they did not do so within
the time limit,
there was a significant delay.
So the failure to disclose
incident reports.
And again, with the auto
defects that we're witnessing in
the press and in the showrooms
today, the same issue applies.
So when did the corporation
know that the pedals stuck or
that the brake system was not
working correctly?
So the failure to report back
to government agencies that have
regulatory responsibilities,
whether it's pharmaceuticals or
cars or pesticides or cosmetics
or foods,
these generally carry
significant penalties.
And because of preemption
that's built into pesticide law
and air quality law,
et cetera, states have often
denied access to courts to use
these theories of recovery to
secure compensation.
So the state courts have often
not agreed to hear the cases.
This is why Bates v.
Dow is so important.
Bates is a case in which
twenty-nine peanut growers in
Texas alleged that Dow
AgroSciences had produced a
chemical called Strong Arm.
Strong Arm, they claimed
damaged their peanut plants back
in the year 2000.
And the pesticide label itself
claimed that "Use of Strong
Arm is recommended in all areas
where peanuts are grown."
Now, when it was used in the
Texas peanut farmland,
where the soils exceeded a pH
of seven point two,
it damaged both the peanut
crop, and it failed to control
the weeds.
So the activity of this
chemical is mediated by the
acidity of the soil.
And by 2001,
EPA had approved a new label
for the chemical,
including a new warning,
"Do not apply Strong Arm
to soils with a pH of seven
point two or greater."
So this case was decided in
2005.
This label was in force for
four years before the decision
date.
So eventually,
the case wound its way up to
the Supreme Court.
And this is quite a feat.
In many instances,
claims that are brought in
state courts do not make their
way up to the Supreme Court.
It can often take decades or
even a half a century before a
case is believed to be
appropriate for judicial review
by the highest court in the
country.
So they found that
"Congress surely would have
expressed its intent more
clearly of it had meant to
deprive injured parties of a
long-available form of
compensation.
Moreover, this history
emphasizes the importance of
providing an incentive to
manufacturers to use the utmost
care in distributing inherently
dangerous items."
In other words,
the Supreme Court was looking
at these lawsuits to seek
recovery as really a last
resort.
So it represents the failure of
federal law,
it represents the failure of
state law or local law to offer
sufficient environmental
protection or protection of
public health.
So what's a damaged party to do?
What are you going to do if
you've been damaged?
Well, you probably would
consider litigation.
So the Supreme Court continued,
"It seems unlikely that
Congress considered a relatively
obscure provision like Section
136VB (which is the preemption
clause) to give pesticide
manufacturers virtual immunity
from certain forms of tort
liability.
And we've been pointed to no
evidence that such tort suits
led to a crazy quilt of FIFRA
(federal pesticide law
standards) or otherwise created
any real hardship for
manufacturers or EPA."
So the argument that you would
have an uneven regulatory
playing field among the states
had no substance to it,
or that the manufacturers would
be damaged significantly by
these claims,
because they're expensive,
they're time consuming,
and few people actually have
the resources or capacity to
bring the lawsuits.
So central questions today
really will involve a question
of freedom of speech and when is
it appropriate to limit speech
about environmental and health
hazards,
intellectual property rights.
Who should own the right to
knowledge of risk?
Should corporations be capable
of holding that as a secret?
Or should they be obligated to
disclose that to the public in
the form of a warning label or a
disclosure of an incident
report?
What should the standard of
proof be?
And how should the falsity of a
statement be judged?
The falsity of a statement on a
label or the falsity of a
statement made by a party that
is challenging a corporation
that they were damaged by
exposure to their product?
And where should the burden of
proof lie?
Should the burden of proof lie
with the plaintiff to prove the
falsity of criticism,
or the defendant to prove truth
of criticism?
And to explore this area of
product disparagement more
fully, I want you to consider
one case.
This is a case of a chemical
known as Alar that you probably
did not experience.
But it was in wide use in the
United States and in different
parts of the world back in the
1980s and early 1990s,
and it was used on apples.
And it was used on apple
orchards basically to cause stem
thickening,
so it would hold the apple on
the tree longer and it would
keep the apple from falling down
and getting bruised.
So it would maintain the
commercial quality and the grade
of the apple.
And it would also cause uniform
ripening.
Uniform ripening is important,
because you don't want part of
a tree,
perhaps that's facing the
sunshine,
to have apples that are ripe
and then all the apples that are
on the north side of the tree in
more shade that would remain
green.
So it provided economic
advantage to orchard owners in a
variety of ways.
This is a systemic compound,
which is interesting.
It means that it's absorbed up
through the plant roots itself
into the plant tissue.
So you may think that some
residues are only on the surface
of a fruit or a vegetable and if
you peel it or if you wash it,
you could get rid of it.
Here's an example of a compound
that that would not be helpful
for.
It's not easy to detect.
When this chemical was being
reviewed and became a public
target for criticism of its
manufacturer,
I went up to the state of
Massachusetts,
because the state of
Massachusetts was trying to
figure out if they were going to
ban the compound,
as it was detected increasingly
in foods.
And I went to their
laboratories,
their state laboratories,
and they had not even developed
a detection method yet.
Speaking to their analytic
chemists, they didn't even know
how to find this in foods.
So think about that for a
minute.
What that means is that the
government approved the use of a
chemical on certain crops when
it knew that there was no
accepted method for detecting it
in the food or in processed
forms of the food or in water
supplies if it happened to
contaminate water supplies.
So that's quite curious and it
might give you some ideas about
prior requirements before
introducing new technologies.
So it has an unusual
characteristic.
It produces unsymmetrical
dimethylhydrazine,
UDMH, which is also a space
shuttle rocket fuel,
but only under conditions where
the chemical is heated.
Now where would food be heated?
Well, it's commonly heated when
it's processed or when it's
pasteurized.
So when you take an apple and
you grind it up and you squeeze
all the juice out of it to make
apple juice,
it's commonly heated up for the
purposes of killing bacteria and
protecting human health.
Apple juice in the 1980s was
also exploding into the
marketplace, in part because of
different packaging
technologies.
So it used to be available in
large glass bottles,
but the advent of juice boxes
so that children would take
these flavored juices to school
on a routine basis in really
small cardboard and plastic
containers,
it caused apple juice
consumption to skyrocket.
So that apple juice,
within a matter of a decade,
became one of the more heavily
consumed foods by young
children.
So it was introduced by
Uniroyal in 1966 and registered
by the Department of
Agriculture, because EPA wasn't
in existence until 1970.
And in 1973,
it was found to produce cancer
in mice.
Between 1977 and '78,
the National Cancer Institute
found that that study was
credible,
and they conducted their own
studies that found carcinogenic
effects in animals,
raising the question how should
we look at data from animal
testing?
And what should we infer from
that about human health risk?
Well, during conservative
political administrations,
we've tended as a society not
to worry too much about these
low level cancer risks in the
food supply.
But remember that at this point
in time,
the Delaney Clause in the Food,
Drug and Cosmetic Act was in
place that had what was called
the de minimis risk
standard built into it.
So it also had the Food and
Drug Administration that was
interpreting the de
minimis standard to allow
low levels of risk in the food
supply.
So EPA concluded eventually in
1980 that it was carcinogenic
and then negotiated with
Uniroyal for several years,
and that produced no action.
In 1985, they found that both
Alar,
which is the parent compound
and the metabolite,
the UDMH, was a "probable
human" carcinogen.
So this is the next step up in
the level of concern.
It's not just an animal
carcinogen--it's "probable
human."
The next step up,
by the way, is "known
human carcinogen."
And there are more than a
hundred now compounds that are
characterized as known human
carcinogens,
such as benzene and
1,3-butadiene,
which exists in diesel exhaust
and other combustion situations,
such as in wood smoke,
or virtually any time fossil
fuel is being combusted.
And in 1985,
some feedback from their own
scientific advisory panel raised
questions about the quality of
the data.
Can you actually calculate a
cancer risk?
So what is the threat?
And what can publicly be stated
about that threat?
Well, the Natural Resources
Defense Council,
one of our largest
environmental groups,
conducted their own analysis of
kids' exposure,
recognizing that kids were
eating a lot of apples and
applesauce and drinking a lot of
apple juice.
It was a very common drink to
be served to infants in place of
infant formula or milk.
And has the EPA violated the
public trust?
So let me see if I can get this
going.
This is a 60 Minutes
report that was prepared on
this controversy.
So that the Natural Resources
Defense Council brought their
study to 60 Minutes and
asked them,
"Would you like to release
this information on your
show?"
And the answer was yes.
Ed Bradley [on video]:
>
--in our food supply was a
substance sprayed on apples to
keep them on the trees longer
and make them look better.
That's the conclusion of a
number of scientific experts.
And who is most at risk?
Children, who may someday
develop cancer from this one
chemical called daminozide.
Daminozide, which has been
sprayed on apples for more than
twenty years,
breaks down into another
chemical called UDMH.
The EPA's acting administrator,
Dr. Jack Moore,
acknowledged that the EPA has
known about the cancer risk for
sixteen years.
Jack Moore [on video]:
There's no question if it
was a new chemical not yet on
the market and it was brought to
the EPA to be evaluated,
that it would not get on the
market,
based on the data that was
available.
Ed Bradley [on video]:
Dr. Moore,
I can't understand that.
I mean, you're telling me
something that if this stuff
came into you just today and it
was brand new,
it wouldn't get on the market.
But because it's already out
there, we can keep using it?
That doesn't make sense to me.
Jack Moore [on video]:
You've just identified one
of the paradoxes of the statute.
What if a pesticide gets its
license,
gets its registration,
is on the market,
despite what everybody might
think,
the burden of carrying
unreasonable risk finding
basically goes onto the
government.
All right?
Ed Bradley [on video]:
But you see,
a lot of these chemicals got on
the market when we didn't know
that they were cancer-causing
agents,
and they're on the market now.
And we know that they do cause
cancer.
But you say we can't take them
off because they're already on
the market and they went on the
market when we didn't know they
caused cancer.
Jack Moore [on video]:
That's the paradox of
statute.
Ed Bradley [on video]:
>
Is it fair to say then,
Dr. Moore,
that there are laws on the
books that are putting us,
particularly our children,
at risk?
Jack Moore [on video]:
Could be.
Ed Bradley [on video]:
While Dr. Moore blames a
law which requires him to
balance the health risks to the
public against the economic
benefits to the growers,
Congressman Jerry Sikorsky
blames the EPA.
Jerry Sikorsky [on video]:
There are two laws.
One is the Food,
Drug and Cosmetic Act that says
quite clearly if this chemical
causes tumor in laboratory
animals,
not malignant tumors,
any kind of tumors,
it's supposed to be pulled off
the market.
Ed Bradley [on video]:
Jack Moore,
the deputy administrator of the
EPA,
says that he'd like to take it
off the market,
but he's afraid that the
manufacturer,
Uniroyal, that makes this
chemical,
could successfully sue the EPA.
Jerry Sikorsky [on video]:
So let them sue.
That's his job.
He's with the Environmental
Protection Agency.
Go to a cancer ward at any
children's hospital in this
country,
see these bald,
wasting away kids,
and then make a decision as to
whether the risks balance over
the benefits.
Ed Bradley [on video]:
Kids are at a high risk
from UDMH because they drink so
much apple juice.
The average preschooler drinks
eighteen times more apple juice
than his or her mother.
If those apples were treated
with daminozide,
the cancer risk is perilously
high.
Janet Hathaway is the senior
attorney for the Natural
Resources Defense Council.
Janet Hathaway [on video]:
What we're talking about
is a cancer-causing agent used
on food that EPA knows is going
to cause cancer for thousands of
children over their lifetime.
Ed Bradley [on video]:
Uniroyal Chemical,
which makes daminozide under
the trade name Alar,
declined to be interviewed for
this report.
But in a letter,
they said, "Any risk from
daminozide or UDMH,
if it exists,
is negligible."
Nonetheless,
preliminary results from
Uniroyal's own study already
show high levels of cancer in
laboratory animals.
Janet Hathaway's organization,
the Natural Resources Defense
Council,
has just completed the most
careful study yet on the effect
of daminozide and seven other
cancer causing pesticides in the
food children eat.
Janet Hathaway [on video]:
Just from these eight
pesticides what we're finding is
that the risk of developing
cancer is approximately 250
times what EPA says is an
acceptable level of cancer in a
population.
Ed Bradley [on video]:
Two hundred and fifty
times?
Janet Hathaway [on video]:
That's right.
What that means is that over a
lifetime, one child out of every
4,000 or so of our preschoolers
will develop cancer just from
these eight pesticides.
Ed Bradley [on video]:
And EPA says acceptable
limit is one out of?
Janet Hathaway [on video]:
One out of a million they
say is acceptable.
Ed Bradley [on video]:
Are they scaring people
needlessly?
Are they fear mongers?
Jack Moore [on video]:
Well, there's no question
that if the risk is greater than
the one in a million
calculation,
it's a cause for concern to
disease.
Ed Bradley [on video]:
You've had a chance to
look at the NRDC study.
It says children are being
bombarded with a pesticide risk
several hundred times greater
than what the agency says is
acceptable.
Jack Moore [on video]:
Risk unacceptable,
yet magnitude of risk is less
by our calculation than
>
Ed Bradley [on video]:
Dr. John Grave a
professor of--
Prof: I'm sorry,
this will take just one second.
**
So think about what Janet
Hathaway, the senior attorney
just said.
"Over a lifetime,
one child out of every 4,000 or
so of our preschoolers will
develop cancer from just these
eight pesticides."
Think about the wording,
the phrasing very carefully.
This is quantitative risk
assessment.
It's loaded with uncertainty
from many different sources.
You're forced to infer from
animal evidence.
You're forced to understand the
pattern of exposure,
how the compound might behave
inside the human body.
Then she said, "Alar,
the most potent cancer causing
agent in our food supply,
is a substance sprayed on
apples to keep them on the trees
longer...And what we're talking
about is a cancer-causing agent
used on food that EPA knows is
going to cause cancer for
thousands of children over their
lifetime."
These are statements of
certainty that caused widespread
fear in the population.
Senator Joe Lieberman spoke to
me during this situation.
And he said he walked
immediately, after watching
60 Minutes,
over to his refrigerator.
He took out his jar of apple
juice and dumped it down the
drain and started making phone
calls.
This happened all over the
country as millions of people
had witnessed this.
Jack Moore, who you saw,
the acting EPA administrator,
said that the evidence,
yes, that he relied upon was
suitable for a decision to say
that Alar indeed was a
carcinogen.
And the media reaction was
really quite striking.
All of the major media outlets
picked this story up,
Newsweek,
et cetera.
Donahue, on The Donahue
Show, he said "Don't
look now, but we're poisoning
our kids."
The consumer reaction was
really quite rapid and
devastating for the apple
industry.
Apple product sales dropped
thirty percent in a month,
particularly on apple juice.
School boards in New York and
Virginia and California stopped
serving apples in their lunch
programs.
Growers claimed losses of $250
million and they engaged in a
lawsuit against both 60
Minutes as well as the
Natural Resources Defense
Council.
Within a matter of six months,
the economic concerns were so
high that the industry itself
was begging EPA to please
regulate and prohibit the use of
this chemical.
Now, that's really quite
striking.
So that you've got really kind
of a very different type of
regulatory theory here.
What is regulation doing?
It's really providing a sense
of legitimacy to manufacturers
of different kinds of products
so that if you know that a
chemical or a product,
it could be a food,
it could be a car.
If you know that it's been
reviewed by a regulatory agency,
that act of regulation really
constitutes certification of
that product's utility and also
its safety in the marketplace.
So the fact that the growers
and the grocery stores and even
Uniroyal asked EPA to move
quickly so that the economic
damage would be limited and
consumer confidence could be
restored,
particularly because this
product was not used on all
apple products.
So it really is a form of
symbolic politics,
which I think is quite
striking.
So that regardless of whether
or not the regulations are
health protective,
they create a sense of
legitimacy of products and
services in the marketplace so
that in one sense,
our corporations need these
regulations so that they create
consumer confidence.
So the Washington apple
growers, there are 4,700 of
them,
claimed that well,
there was no evidence linking
Alar to human cancer and the
animal evidence was
insufficient,
and they called this a product
disparagement or a trade libel
case.
And in this situation,
the growers faced the burden of
proof.
So they needed to prove that
the statements were made
knowingly to be false,
the statements were
deliberately made to induce
monetary damage.
And this is a form of trade
libel law, defamation.
So there are several forms of
libel, slander,
and sedition.
Libel, the definition is
defamation through print
materials.
Slander is oral defamation.
In the English common law
tradition, libel in private
enterprise generally found
favorably to plaintiffs.
And sedition,
you'll recall,
is any political criticism that
tended to diminish respect for
government, laws,
and public officials.
The common law definition of
libel was decided by a famous
court case in 1933.
It covers "all written
communications that tend to
expose one to public hatred,
shame, obloquy,
contumely, odium,
contempt,
ridicule, aversion,
ostracism, degradation,
or disgrace,
and to induce an evil opinion
of one in the minds of
right-thinking persons and to
deprive one of their confidence
and friendly intercourse in
society."
Well in this case,
the Ninth Circuit Court of
Appeals found on the absence of
human studies that "The
fact that there had been no
studies conducted specifically
on the cancer risks to children
form daminozide,
one of the arguments on the
part of the industry,
does nothing to disprove the
conclusion that if children
consume more of a carcinogenic
substance than do adults,
they are at higher risk for
contracting cancer."
So what's interesting about
this comment by the appellate
court is that they're not
looking for proof that this
chemical caused cancer in
children.
They're looking for elevated
cancer risk.
And on the falsity of the
statements, a product
disparagement plaintiff has the
burden of proving the falsity.
And this statement refers to
individuals, not to any overall
message.
And if a jury were given the
task of interpreting the
uncertainty of a message,
it raises the specter of a
chilling effect on speech.
So think about the relationship
between this type of a court
case and the freedom of the
individual to express themselves
or express their opinion about
the dangers of different
products or human behaviors.
So this case was decided by the
Ninth Circuit fundamentally on a
First Amendment choice referring
back to a famous New York
Times v. Sullivan
case in 1964,
where Sullivan,
who was a police commissioner
in Alabama brought a libel
action against four African
American clergy and the New
York Times.
The Times had published
an advertisement back in 1960 in
support of civil rights activism
among students,
a struggle for the right to
vote, a legal defense of Martin
Luther King against a perjury
charge,
and charges of repressive
police misconduct,
including false statements.
And the trial judge had
instructed the jury that the
advertisement was libelous,
that legal injury was implied,
that falsity and malice are
presumed,
and that punitive damages
should be awarded.
So that in this case,
the Supreme Court found that it
was constitutionally deficient
for failure to safeguard freedom
of speech in the press required
by the First and the Fourteenth
Amendment.
And debate on public issues
should be uninhibited,
robust, wide open,
and that it may well include
vehement,
caustic, and sharp attacks on
government and public officials.
With respect to actual malice,
because in order to find
disparagement or liability in
this situation,
there's a need to demonstrate
actual malice.
The constitutional guarantees
require a federal rule that
prohibits a public official from
recovering damages for
defamatory falsehood relating to
his official conduct unless he
proves that the statement was
made with actual malice.
What's malice?
Well, it's with knowledge that
the claim was false when it was
made, or with reckless disregard
of whether it was false.
And the burden of demonstrating
the falsity rests on the
plaintiff.
Now, this seems to give the
media a fairly wide berth in the
kinds of claims that they can
make.
In the wake of this case,
many states passed what are
thought of now and labeled as
veggie libel laws.
So that rather than placing the
burden on a plaintiff to
demonstrate the falsity of the
statement,
they place the burden on the
individual that makes the claim
of significant risk or hazard.
So there are many states that
have adopted this statutory
change.
And what this means is that it
opens the way for slap suits.
What is a slap suit?
It basically is a suit that
intimidates people from making
claims about the quality of the
environment or causes of its
loss or subsequent health
damages.
So among these twenty or so
states that have adopted these
laws, for example,
now I will not give a lecture
where I am making a claim of
risk.
So that might be thought of as
a chilling effect on free speech
in a way.
So if I'm, say,
being taped on a radio show,
that radio show is broadcast in
a state where one of these
veggie libel laws exists that
would place the burden on me to
demonstrate the proof that my
claim is backed up by high
quality science,
that will pull me into court,
it will cost me thousands of
dollars,
hundreds of thousands of
dollars even,
to defend myself.
So that the influence of this
form of law is really quite
striking.
What also is interesting about
this evolution of state laws
that reverse the burden of proof
is that clearly it's been found
by the Supreme Court as being an
unconstitutional shift in the
burden.
Yet none of these state laws
have been taken up to the
Supreme Court for consideration.
So think about that.
These laws have been in place
now for well over a decade,
and all environmental groups,
all public health interest
groups understand the nature of
these laws and they're all very
self-conscious about the nature
of the claims that they make.
Now, I want to show you this.
Oprah Winfrey hosted a show on
mad cow disease.
Mad cow disease is an illness
that is caused by a prion and
believed to be associated with
beef that are feed other cattle
parts in their cattle meal.
So Winfrey hosted Howard Lyman,
who described the process of
slaughterhouses and beef
rendering and how the parts were
ground up and then put into
animal feed and fed back in the
United States to cattle that
were sold for food.
And this was the mechanism that
he and others believed had
caused the outbreak of mad cow
disease in Great Britain.
Now there are laws that prevent
that from happening,
but at this point in time,
this represents another rather
interesting case on product
disparagement.
** Give me one second
here.
** I've lost my
internet connection,
so we're on hold for a moment.
** My apology for that
delay.
Howard Lyman [on video]:
With me on the stage,
to the left of me a grandmother
whose granddaughter is dying of
the human form of mad cow
disease in England.
To the right of me,
a guy from the National Cattle
and Beef Association,
points at me and says
"Here is a man who believes
within ten years we could have
diseases that make AIDS look
like the common cold."
And I said, absolutely.
And she said,
"That's such a strong
statement."
I said, "Oprah,
we have 100,000 cows a year
alive at night,
dead in the morning.
We round them up,
grind them up,
turn them into feed,
feed them back to other cows.
We go out and collect road
kill, deer, elk,
possum, raccoons,
scrape them up off of the
street, grind them up,
and feed them back to cows.
And then we take pets,
city of Los Angeles,
200 tons of pets,
full of chemicals that were
used to kill them,
200 tons a month are ground up,
turned into feed,
and fed back to our food
animals."
This time Oprah's eyes are as
big as saucers.
I knew that I'd got her.
She turns around and looks at
the guy from the National Cattle
and Beef Association and says,
"Dr. Weber,
are we feeding cows to
cows?"
I'll never **
what he had to say,
he said, "Well,
you know, there's a limited
amount of that going on."
I believe that about
ninety-five percent of the
cattle fed back in factory feed
lots are eating the remains of
other animals.
And the next thing out of
Oprah's mouth then gets us sued.
Oprah says, "That just
stops me cold.
I will never again eat a
burger."
Now, she didn't say,
"I think the meat's
infected."
She didn't say to the millions
of viewers, "You shouldn't
eat any."
She just said,
"That stops me cold.
I will never again eat a
burger."
Now I knew when I went on that
show that thirteen states had a
thing called the food
disparagement law.
The food disparagement law says
that it's against the law to say
something you know to be false
about a perishable commodity.
I didn't say anything I thought
to be false.
I told the truth.
Well, we were taping the show,
took about two hours.
When we got done taping the
show I walked up to Oprah and I
said to her,
I said, "Hey Oprah,
give me ten minutes,
I'll get you off of
chicken."
Oprah looked at me and said,
"Only one animal a
day."
<<audience
laughter>>
So, I went about my business.
Couple weeks later,
I got a call that said,
"Do you realize you're
being sued with Oprah Winfrey
and Harpo Production by a group
of Texas cattlemen?"
And I said, "No,
can I put you on hold?"
I raced into my library,
I inventoried my vegetarian
cookbooks.
I knew those cattlemen wanted
those vegetarian cookbooks bad.
I went back and said,
"I can't talk to you right
now, I've got to put in a call
to Oprah."
I called Oprah and left a
message, and I said,
"Oprah,
if we lose this suit,
I'm going to throw in my
vegetarian cookbooks.
You've got to put up the
money."
Well, we end up getting sued in
Amarillo, Texas.
I don't know how many of you
have ever been to Amarillo,
Texas.
It's not the end of the world,
but it's clearly visible from
there.
If you're going to give the
world an enema you take the hose
to Amarillo, Texas.
The largest employer in
Amarillo, Texas,
happens to be the slaughter
facility killing cattle.
Bumper stickers all over town
said, "The only mad cow in
Texas is named Oprah."
I knew we were in trouble when
I went and saw my lawyer,
and I said to him,
"We need a change of
venue.
There is no way in the world
that we can win here in
Amarillo."
So we filed with the judge for
a change of venue.
We walked in, who's the judge?
Seventy-two-year-old lady,
a tough old heifer.
We asked for a change of venue,
she picks up the hammer,
slaps it down,
and says, "Motion denied.
Bring in the jury pool."
They brought 140 people in.
You never saw so many hats,
boots, and belt buckles in all
your life.
I said to my lawyer,
"We need to find an
appeal, because there's no way
in the world that we're going to
win here."
At the end of the day,
we had twelve jurors,
absolutely steeped in the
cattle culture.
My lawyer, he looks at me and
he said, "They're going to
call you to the stand
tomorrow."
He said, "The first
question they're going to ask
you is whether or not you are a
vegetarian."
I said, "I can handle
that."
He said, "You damn well
better, you'll lose."
Sure enough,
the next day they called me to
the stand.
I'm on the stand with the
plaintiff's attorney is looking
at me, laughing and giggling.
And he says,
"I can't hardly say this.
Hey, Mr. Lyman,
is it true that you are a--
>
--a vegetarian?"
And I looked at the jury and
said, "I will not apologize
for something that has saved my
life."
Never again in that trial did
they ever ask me about why I was
a vegetarian.
But they asked me every
question you can imagine.
I'm on the stand,
the lawyer looks at me and he
says, "Mr. Lyman,
has anybody ever called you
irresponsible?"
I said, "Yes."
My lawyer's sitting over there
going, "No,
no, no."
The plaintiff's attorney thinks
he's found the key to the
Gordian Knot.
And he looks at me and he says,
"Who?"
I said, "My wife."
And the jury's over there,
been there, done that.
We were in that courtroom for
six weeks.
At the end of six weeks,
that jury found Oprah,
Harpo Production and myself not
liable.
The plaintiffs went out of
their tree.
They could not imagine that
that jury, that homegrown jury,
could find out-of-towners not
liable.
And they appealed with the
Fifth Circuit Court of Appeals.
We spent a year in the Fifth
Circuit Court of Appeals.
And at the end of the year,
they came down with a unanimous
panel decision that Oprah,
Harpo Production and myself
were not liable.
And then they wrote an opinion
that said,
"Everything that Lyman
said on the show was true and
the truth is not
actionable."
The cattlemen couldn't stand
that and asked
>
for a rehearing.
It was denied.
And then the cattlemen got
together and went to state court
and filed suit against Oprah,
Harpo Production and myself
with the state court.
Thank God I did not live in
Texas.
I was able to move it from the
state court to the federal
court.
They appealed that.
We spent six years,
hundreds of thousands of
dollars of my money defending
>
to tell the truth.
At the end of six years the
judge finally threw out the case
with prejudice,
which meant the jury,
or the plaintiffs could not
re-file the case,
that the statute of limitations
had run out.
So it became six years,
hundreds of thousands of
dollars, we were finally
vindicated for standing up and
telling the truth.
Prof: So the core of
this problem is the way that
these state veggie libel laws
shift the burden of proof.
So under federal law,
it's really clear that the
Cattlemen's Association was
under the burden of proof to
demonstrate that the statement
was knowingly false and
delivered with malice with the
intent to harm.
But under state law,
Oprah's burden was to
demonstrate that the statement
is true with reasonable
certainty.
So I'll leave you with one
thought on this,
and the importance of
fashioning law in a way that
would protect free speech and
open access to knowledge of risk
and opinions on the part of
experts.
Justice Powell,
in 1974 on truth and free
speech,
"There's no such thing as
a false idea,
no matter how pernicious an
opinion may seem,
we depend its correction not on
the conscience of judges and
juries,
but on the competition of other
ideas."
So that's it for today.
Have a great weekend.